The conclusion I've come to is you do
not have a technological and here I'm
going to be uh rude but it's on purpose.
There's no technological solution to
stupid. People are going to believe what
they want to believe. You can deep fake
Donald Duck on Camala Harris or Donald
Trump and if they want to believe what
they say they're going to believe it.
You can put a box around it. You can put
warnings on it. It doesn't matter. So
the purpose for us is a to identify the
markets where they actually need our
tech to help them. B how to
uh uh combat the the what's the word I'm
looking for? The cognitive bias which is
the confirmation bias you have when you
go online to see what you want to see.
And there's a new branch of of cognitive
science. I believe it's called cognitive
immunity that people are talking about
where at the end of the day like in
everything cyber you're a cyber security
specialist I'm not the weakest link is
the individual so at the end of the day
everything we supply is a tool to
empower an individual to know if
something is real or not but the
decision the reality
that you say in German the real the real
fuse is in your brain if you don't want
to believe or you want to believe
There's no amount of technology that's
going to to solve that issue.
[Music]
Anthony Sahakian, thank you so much for
for joining me today. Uh really excited
to have you with me at the Human Zero
Day. Um, and you know, I we we just
talked about how you pretty much you're
uh one of the first people in the world
to be looking into deep fakes and deep
fake detection before uh practically
they existed in many regards. H but
we'll get into that in a minute. So, so
I'm really excited to to dive into this
world with you. Thank you for being here
with me. My pleasure. Thank you for
inviting me. Absolutely. Anthony, how do
you get into deep fakes all the way back
in 2016? What what prompts that? First
of all, let's be clear. Deep fake is a
term that was coined in 2017, I think.
So, this journey started actually where
you are in Israel where a very good
friend of mine and my co-founder came to
me uh and said, I want to build a
company to detect real from fake in the
digital world. At the time, I had spent
101 15 years in Russia and Central Asia.
Uh I've I've dealt with misinformation,
malinformation, and disinformation. I've
lived it as a foreigner living in very
authoritarian countries. And to me, it
was a no-brainer that we would need
software to distinguish real from fake
in the digital world. And I was an
investor. I put money in. Uh the company
started in Tel Aviv. It didn't work.
They were using signals processing
technology. This is 2016.
Um didn't work. Couldn't work. Couldn't
scale. At the time, I didn't know what I
was doing. I'm a political scientist. I
made my money in bricks and mortar
businesses in Moscow and Central Asia.
But I like the idea and I got on a
train. I went to EPFL which is one of
our top learning universities.
There I met and got to know the chairman
of JPEG. And at the time he looks at me
and Taj, a friend of mine. He said,
"Yeah, I think there's something here.
The way to do it is with a Swiss
government grant. Let's apply for a
project detecting real from fake
multimodel, but you need to use AI." And
this is 2016. I mean, nobody nobody was
using it. So, we wrote the project and
in the middle of the project, the whole
deep fake thing exploded. And we found
ourselves researching an issue. At the
time, nobody could predict deep fake.
Now, anybody who tells you they could
have predicted what happened, I think,
is lying. It's But we could
see that they would be
exponentially better tools. At the time,
we're looking at Photoshop to to change
things. So, my partner originally wanted
to do this in social media because he
has five kids and he was very worried
about what they were seeing and the
influence they were getting. Uh, I was
sitting in Switzerland and I thought,
okay, it's a good idea, but how about we
do it B2B? I'm too old to roll the dice
on a one in 10 chance in success. Let's
do a B2B project focusing more on what
we thought would be the use case
insurance claim management. uh we're
still looking at that and
opportunistically ID management came to
us too. Is it real passport, fake
passport, that kind of stuff? So um it's
a very big space. It's not going away.
And you know when they came to me as an
angel investor in the very beginning, it
was a no-brainer. Yeah, we need this
now. Can we do it? How do we take it to
market? That's all secondary. And I went
all in as I usually do in everything I
do. I hope that's um
and is that explanatory enough? Well,
absolutely. But there's still a path
from from being from being an angel
investor to actually being a a founder.
I took the company over. I took the
company over. So, we couldn't do it with
a technology. It means that we sent
money to Tel Aviv. They couldn't do it
with signals processing. So, I founded a
Swiss company. I took the company over
and uh we decided to do it with an AI
approach. This is 2017, very early 2017.
2018 we got a grant from the Swiss
government to research and develop this
issues. And I think if we'd have to
check this, but I think deep fake, the
term was coined in the middle of 2018,
something like that. Yeah. Research.
Yeah. That I believe the term first
appeared on a on a Reddit thread
somewhere between and and 2018.
Obviously deep deep learning. Deep
learning. Yeah, exactly. So before we we
planned the project before this all hit,
but we're in the middle of it. So we had
the correct vision. Now let's see if we
can execute. Yeah. Abs. So so you've
you've been at this for a while. So So
what are some of your what what are some
of your intuition back in 17 about 2016
2017 about deep fake detection? So
you're seeing this thing coming. You're
you're identifying opportunities in B2B
and particularly in insurance and
identities.
They came to us identity. We didn't
think about that. I mean, every day I
have people contact us with use cases
that we hadn't thought about. And the
biggest problem we have, I'm sure you're
facing it too, is when we engage with
customers. They want everything in the
kitchen sink and they want it in real
time. They want the results yesterday
and they want it for free. So, you know,
it's it's managing expectations is a big
part of of what we do. I'm sorry I
interrupted you, Michael. I apologize.
Please go ahead. No, no, all no. This is
this is the nature of it. Uh, but what
what are your what are your intuitions
back then? So, you're taking over.
You're going to now run the technology.
You're going to use AI in 2017. You get
a grant from the Swiss government to use
AI to provide good signal processing to
to distinguish real from fake. How do
you go about this? In what sense? Well,
what what are some of your is it is it I
mean how do you approach this
technologically? I guess not not just
not necessarily from the neural network
architecture, but you mean you're
sitting with your team in Switzerland
and and what is sort of the mission? Do
we do any deep fake detection video
audio? How do you go about it? No, no,
no, no, no. We wanted to build a a a a
model that was agnostic and could be
trained up for the use cases here. I'm
not giving you anything proprietary. I'm
sure you know better than I do. The real
problem is the data and the real problem
is the focus. Because you could maybe
envision
something like a large language model
architecture that could detect a lot of
different use cases, but it won't detect
it precisely. And when you're dealing
with things like insurance or ID
management, they're asking for less than
1% false positive, false negative. These
are very difficult nuts to crack. So
what we learned is the more focused you
are on what you're doing, the better
your product. And it's a mistake to try
and do everything for everybody because
you can't. So we are now focusing on one
or two uh uh uh uh products that we're
rolling out very targeted uh and very
specific to certain sectors. We made the
mistake of going too wide wanting to do
too much. And what you find is you can't
do anything properly. None of the
clients are happy. So we had to pivot
come back to something a bit more
focused. I won't go too much into detail
about that and the real key is the data
and with Europe you have GDPR you have
data constrictions uh it's not easy but
we figured a way to do that. So the real
question as a business is one is where
can we bring the most uh where can we be
the most useful but also we have to
monetize it and it's not that easy to
monetize uh you know as I'm sure you're
Go ahead. Yeah. I mean, so you've
watched the world adapt to this concept
of deep fakes over the last eight years,
right? So 2016, the term isn't even
being used. I guess 2020 is when you
have Obama, right, with Peele and the
and then deep Tom Cruz. So, and only
really in the last, I guess, two years,
you're seeing mainstream conversations
about deep fakes. only at the beginning
of this year you see the first real
mainstream
significant attack of millions of
dollars worth um and probably you and I
both know that there have been attacks
before but this was the one that made
the biggest the biggest um headlines
where has where how have how has the
world adapted in your eyes okay to the
deep fake threat walk me through the
eight-year journey for you I'm going to
tell you something feel free to edit out
or deep fake by by my audio for this.
The conclusion I've come to is you do
not have a technological and here I'm
going to be uh rude, but it's on
purpose. There's no technological
solution to stupid. People are going to
believe what they want to believe. You
can deep fake Donald Duck on Camala
Harris or Donald Trump and if they want
to believe what they say, they're going
to believe it. You can put a box around
it. You can put warnings on it. It
doesn't matter. So the purpose for us is
a to identify the markets where they
actually need our tech to help them. B
how to
uh uh combat the the what's the word I'm
looking for? The cognitive bias which is
the confirmation bias you have when you
go online to see what you want to see.
And there's a new branch of of cognitive
science. I believe it's called cognitive
immunity that people are talking about
where at the end of the day like in
everything cyber you're a cyber security
specialist I'm not the weakest link is
the individual so at the end of the day
everything we supply is a tool to
empower an individual to know if
something is real or not but the
decision the real
you say in German the real the real fuse
is in your brain if you don't want to
believe or you want to believe there's
no amount of technology that's going to
to solve that issue. So, it's a
double-edged sword. One, you want to
make the attacks more expensive uh than
the defense. Two, you're never going to
have something or at least very
difficult to uh that's 100% efficient,
doesn't exist.
And three, you got to target it for your
market and you got to build a product
around it for them. So then you run into
the issue of how do you build something
that can scale that has potential to go
to market and at the same time be
efficient and save your customers time,
money and in your case in Israel. I mean
you have a lot I mean I'll give you an
example. We were speaking with the
governments of Indonesia and Pakistan.
You can imagine the damage that a deep
faked uh was it Malala Yusf was another
young lady who was falsely accused of
burning a Quran. and she never, you
know, now, now if you actually have this
on video,
they're very concerned about that. Now,
what good would it do to tell people
half an hour later that it wasn't true,
it didn't happen, they're not going to
believe it. So, it it becomes a very
difficult difficult not to crack. We are
not focusing on that because I don't
think we can solve that issue. That has
to be done by local governments. Maybe
technology like yours or ours can help
them, but that's an education process.
you know, you're not going to stop an
angry mob from storming something
with a targeted deep fake, at least not
sitting in Palo Alto.
And so you're making, I think, a very
clear distinction between social,
society, cognitive biases, the
perception of distinguishing truth and
and you reality from from lies and fake,
right? And then there's the world of
business and the world and you touched
on insurance and different use cases
within I guess the the businessto
business perspective of where you really
want to defend the human as the weakest
link. And it sounds to me like pretty
early on you you were you navigated
towards the B2B landscape in the context
of protecting the human. And am I am I
correct?
Um, how about giving the human the human
giving a human the tools necessary to
protect himself or giving an added uh
arrow to his quiver
um to detect things quickly because now
you can't tell. You know, you can have
one of these large language models fake
something and there's no way the human
eye can tell this. You know, I'll give
you one simple example. one of our
softwares can detect a use case. We
we're in the data rooms of our clients.
If you do it by hand and if you have
experts, maybe in half an hour they can
tell you that it's it's it's it's a fake
image. Our software can do it in 3
seconds. So that's the kind of thing
we're focusing on where we streamline a
business process. We make it move faster
and we give the client the tools to
detect real from fake quickly in a
situation where they need a room full of
30, 40, 50 people at least and they're
not even sure of being able to do it. So
that's the kind of thing we're focusing
on, Michael. Right. And who who are the
early adopters of this in your eyes?
That's a very difficult nut to crack.
Now you have to decide as a business
where you're going. we have a a
direction that I'm convinced is the
right one after having made a lot of
false starts. I'm not going to share
that too much in detail, but I would say
you would have to come to the US for
early adoption of this technology. I'm
not sure about the business environment
in Israel. We had offices there. I've
interacted with Israel, but I I I can't
speak for it because as I was telling
you on our call earlier, the US has one
superpower. You better be doing 1%
better than you did yesterday. Be it in
your personal life or your corporate
life, you're judged on next quarter's
results. You have an incentive because
you have a stock option that's vesting
because your earnings are tied to to to
to bonuses in equity. That doesn't exist
in Europe. So, it's obvious for me.
That's why I moved the company and
myself here. You got to start in the US
or if not the US. I I can't speak for
China or Southeast Asia. I don't know
it. But the issue we had in Europe too
is Europe is the illusion of a single
market. We were pitching to big
insurance companies and you're pitching
to the same company in Paris, Madrid,
Berlin,
different politics in each office,
different decision makers. Half the time
because it's human nature, they think
their nephew can do it or their cousin
can do it or the people they've been
working with for years. So if you're
going to start somewhere, you might as
well do your PC's in a country that's as
big as the US where if you sign one
contract here might be more difficult,
but at least you get the whole country
and then you come to Europe saying,
"Hey, this is what the Americans are
doing. We suggest you do it too." The
other way around just doesn't make to me
again. I could be proven wrong. We might
have to pivot again. But having been
studied here and being educated in the
US, I've forgotten what this country is
really about. And it's about efficiency,
you know. You don't have August off. You
know, you don't have kids that were
paying above market in Paris machine
learning guys. The first question is how
many weeks paid vacation do we get?
Which is fine, but maybe not in a
startup early early stage. I can give
you a bunch of anecdotes on Yeah. Well,
Anthony, it sounds like a an immense
amount of learning under your belt over
these last eight years. But if I'm
looking now at the at at the areas in
which so let's look at human security in
the context of businesses and I'm really
curious to hear your perspective. Sure.
There are many ways in which humans
engage with digital media, digital
content communication like we're doing
now. Here we are in 2024. Where are the
areas where do you think businesses
should be most concerned about in the
context of the the the cyber security
warfare on the human mind where in what
where is the business that that CISOs or
security professionals should be really
concerned with okay well here I have to
be a bit careful because I don't want to
give away uh what we're doing exactly
but what we're talking about basically
in our space I think aside from all the
processes you can automate, I mean, you
know about these. There's nothing
nothing magical about that is the social
engineering aspect of deep fake. But the
problem you're going to have is as a
subsection of great apes,
I think humans for the most part are
reactive.
We have to wait for something to happen
in order to take action to you know uh
to cont to stop it. One one of my
biggest questions I met a guy who's
Amazon is going to compete with Starlink
soon. They're putting up satellites
fast. They're buying land. So I met one
of the heads of the project and I asked
him so not that I know anything about
this subject but top of my head is so
what are you doing to ensure that your
satellites are rugged? What do you mean?
and said, "Well, you know, I think it
was a Carrington event, 1849, 1859,
solar flare, wiped out most of the
telephone or telegraph cables around the
world at that time. We're overdue. What
happens if a solar flare hits your
satellite? Are you ready for that?" And
the guy had no answer. So, he hadn't
even thought of that.
So, it's very difficult to sell
something to people before the problem
is it's coming is a real one. I will add
to that that I'm aware because some of
our clients have spoken to us about deep
faked social engineered spear fishing
attacks that have hit CEOs. They've lost
tens of millions in this. But you're not
going to hear about it. You know, no
company is going to come up and say,
"Yeah, we we sent the fake CEO 30
million last week. It it was a deep fake
call." It's happening and it's going to
happen more and more. So, we're thinking
about products to defend people about
that. Sorry, against these type of
attacks. We're thinking about how to do
it. Uh we we have our thoughts and and
that's what we're focusing on. We want
to be able to produce a tool that will
help uh people
uh uh uh resist spear fishing attacks.
Uh so we have a strategy that that's
what we're focusing on. Do you think
that and again it's not not necessarily
not not to give away any any of the way
things that you're specifically doing. I
obviously understand the the sensitivity
behind it, but in from the insights
you've gathered, do you think that the
right approach is more so in helping
teach humans to be better listeners and
better skeptics of reality? Or is it
more so in let's provide more
anti-ishing automated,
you know, detection solutions? because
those are neither of those have been
hugely successful in the context of
social engineering, right? Email
security has has some great successes.
Uh awareness and training has
historically been primarily for uh
compliance purposes. So h how do you see
you know businesses actually protecting
people from from social engineering and
spear fishing because they're getting
really really good. That's a very good
question. Obviously, education is at the
core of all of this, but you can't
educate everybody all the time. The risk
you have if you step in with software is
to be accused of bias one way or the
other. Um, it's a serious risk. Whatever
you're doing, whether you're you're on
the right or the left or the middle, it
doesn't matter. Any human engineered
tool will have some bias if if it's even
just unconscious in it. Um, I think at
the bottom line it's to interact with
your customers to teach them to be
skeptical about everything and to give
them a tool that they can click on or
that works automatically in the
background to help them with this if
there's even a shadow doubt about
something. We're working on that right
now. How we're doing it that I will keep
um under wraps for the What are you guys
doing, Michael? What's your point? How
what's your thought? Well, we're looking
at how businesses are experiencing the
pain. So, we've been really looking at,
you know, the way that deep fakes are
impacting societal issues from news to
legal and forensics and and really
really really proud of the work we've
done in forensically analyzing the deep
fakes and being able to reliably uh
determine whether an identity is is
synthetically generated or or lip-synced
or phase swapped. And I've been growing
more and more curious about the way that
enterprises are experiencing these pain
points because I think as you said it's
it's a curious problem when you you have
to experience the the problem as a
mainstream issue before you proactively
take measures against it. It becomes an
even bigger issue when you don't
necessarily share when you're
experiencing the problem. And so it's
almost like every business would
potentially have to experience it on
their own before they proactively look
for solutions, right? And I will add to
that if if you're the employee at the
company that's victiming of it, you
probably if you can get away with not
reporting it, you will because it's not
in your interest. You'll probably lose
your job. So um that's something I think
we figured out a way to fix. And I I
won't share that on this podcast, but
I'm working towards something now. Well,
I'm I'm wishing you I'm wishing you best
of luck with with it with what sounds to
be like a solution that you thought long
and hard about, especially since you've
been at this for eight years. So, I So,
I really do think hope that you that you
succeed with it. Um I I'm I'm curious to
hear your perspective on the future of
of the space. Well, there there's
there's there's a thought out there. I
read a book. I think it was called
convergence that everything is
converging.
Now if you add an exponential curve of
technological growth which is coming now
will it have what will you call it? Will
it be will it be the hockey stick curve
or will it be like this? We don't know.
Quantum computing is coming it might be
in 50 years. It might be tomorrow. We
don't know yet. We have to look at a
period of exponential growth where I
think just defining what is real and
what is virtual is going to be very
difficult in 20 years. I mean you have
all of these VR AR it's coming. Will we
integrate with technology? You know will
we all have a neural link embedded or
something similar to it in 20 years?
What's the world going to look like? I I
can't answer that. The same way at the
time we were looking at this, we were
looking at tools like Photoshop who
would make uh image and video
manipulation child play. We never
imagined in 2016 that you would have
DALI or or any of these things out there
where you could just talk to the damn
thing. I mean this was so what's coming
I would be a fool to say I know but I
know something is coming and this is a
space we have to be in unless we decide
to merge with machines and merge with
the virtual space and and live a matrix
life or you know neurommancia type
future that might be what's there I hope
not you know I haven't enjoyed walking
around Silicon Valley and see kids have
more intimate relationships with their
smartphones than with other people I
don't think that's Good. I think
arguably our first encounter as a
species, and this isn't me, this is
something I read somewhere, is with the
AI algorithms on social media. And how
did that work out for us?
So, it's going to be a challenging time.
You know, the trick for a company like
yours and mine is how to develop
technology that we think is for the good
of humanity
and keep it monetizable at the same time
because as you said, uh it's not that
easy to convince people that it's
necessary or it's needed until it's too
late. Anyway, that's my two cents,
Michael. Sorry, Anthony. Thank you so
much for taking the time to uh My
pleasure, sir. to share this with me.
honored having one of the very very
pioneers of deep fake detection and we
fell into it backwards by accident. That
was this is pure pure pure you know pure
luck right time right place but yeah
wishing you best of luck with your
integrity and excited to see the
solution you let me know when you're in
Palo Alto Michael please I'm in Palo
Alto myself when you're here let me know
we'll have lunch or dinner sometime be a
pleasure thank you thank you so That's